nafsi cousin your sorrow your agree for
Oh craps us and that's it that's good
but then the Carvey did it first
imagine every morning you wake up you
can't remember who you are your name is
ml RZ backwards movie starring jewelry
Carey and mosses other movie CSI my
wifey dr. dangle Joey pants his pants
and Ned Ned Ryerson so if you're a Nolan
fanboy enjoy the best movie ever made
until the Dark Knight which I guess was
the best movie ever made until inception
which according to you all was the best
movie ever made until the Dark Knight
Rises
look he's proved himself as a great
filmmaker but you fanboys rate Dark
Knight Rises / citizen in Cain Dark
Knight Rises isn't even the Citizen Kane
of Batman movies something doesn't feel
right
I think someone's thrill as leni
attempts to keep his world in order in a
pre smartphone era who is he utilizes
Polaroids pen and paper trust me Newton
right this town and of course his
tattoos they're one part case file fact
6 car license sg-1 37 I use one part
to-do list and one part lyrics from a
new metal song memory is treachery hmm I
wonder which tad reminds him to keep
frosting is here every few weeks yeah
okay fine
prepare to be shocked by revelations
like the sky isn't who he says he is and
he's actually manipulating Leonard don't
believe his lies this girl isn't who she
says she is and is actually manipulating
Leonard
and shockingly this guy isn't who he
says he is and is actually manipulating
Leonard I lie to myself to be happy yes
I will
genius me Leonard a single mindedly
obsessed white guy with slicked back
hair
aka your typical Christopher Nolan
protagonist he's a shorter man named
Jack who can't remember anything after
his injury somebody hit me from behind I
remember it's about the last thing that
I do remember except for the details of
the condition he developed after his
injury hmm well that's the thing I have
this condition the condition
I guess I've already told you about my
condition my condition because of my
condition I have this condition he won't
rest until he gets revenge for the death
of his wife even though it seems like
they didn't have the best relationship
to begin with how can you read then
again don't be a prick not reading it to
annoy you I enjoy it oh she's just not
that into you bro return to an era when
all the best movies lie to you until the
very end and experience a twisting story
told in Reverse where you already know
what happens but keeps you guessing as
to why I don't know because if you put
it in chronological order it's just a
dude who makes a really long phone call
describing what's wrong with him then
tricks himself into shooting someone
brilliant from the Michael Bay for
people who've read a book in their life
comes the film that kick-started that
world's Christopher Nolan obsession and
made people mildly aware of his brother
you are the directors brother this is
not the first time you've worked you got
the crack now it should be the fifth
time we've worked
pimento
[Music]
I am so confused to see this trailer
frontways click above to watch our
honest trailer commentary for momento
when there's no more room in Hell the
Dead will walk the earth winter came for
house fray one last ride for a for
comment not found stop I want to talk
about cheese